Military bases and embassies, contrary to popular opinion,  don't count as American soil;
though, they're close.
The country hosting the base agrees that her laws don't apply within the base, but the base is still on her land.
That she owns.
Because it's hers.
In her country.
This is called extraterritoriality,
and it isn't unique to the United States,
but it's notable with her because of its frequency,
and in one case,
(Guantanamo Bay, Cuba), contention.
The short version of this story is:
Cuba used to be a U.S. territory,
(taken after the Spanish-American War
with Puerto Rico, and Guam, and Spain's pride).
Cuba eventually went her own way,
but the U.S. naval base, in Guantanamo Bay,
stayed where it was and the U.S. payed to rent the land.
But then, revolución, and
disagreement between Cuba and the U.S. over the rent,
leading to the current awkward situation:
where the U.S. says to Cuba,
"Thank you for renting us this land!"
and Cuba says,
"We didn't rent you that land."
and the U.S. says,
"Here's our rent payment!"
and Cuba says,
"We don't accept that. Please leave?"
and the U.S. says,
"Thank you for renting us this land!"